よろしくお願いします
一年間の一番忙しい時
皆様方はまあ説教なんか説法なんかは聞く暇がないだろうと思いますけど
それでもここに大変来ていただきまして
大変感謝いたします  体は大変忙しい時期ですから
まあ心は混乱状態だろうと思いますけど
この知恵の話なんですけどね
まあ知恵の話もまあいくら言えば
まあなんか混乱の話のようなものですからね
まあ合うかもしれませんね
この時期 では早速話に入りますけど
まあこの頃 この夜なんかね
まあ最終電車とかね 夜遅く電車になんか乗ったら
まあ時々やるんですね
で 突然電車が動かないんですね
それですごい満員でぎゅうぎゅうでいて
ドア閉めたままで 電車が止まったままで
いら立つんでしょうね
その時はもう早く家へ帰りたいし
またそこら辺で酔いつぶれてる人でもそばにいたら
どうしても早く帰りたくなるでしょうし
体が入ってしまっちゃったら大変だからね
で その時やっぱりアナウンスされるんですね
人が線路に落ち落ちましたとか
あるいは人身事故が起きましたとかね
もうしばらく待ってくださいと
あのアナウンス聞いたところで
私たちはどうなるんですかというと
我々のいら立ちが消えちゃうんですね
ああ そうかと じゃあ待たなくちゃいけないんだと
まあ結構遅くなるだろうと
で それで我々のいら立ちが消えちゃうんです
もし逆にあの 想定してみましょう
電車に乗ってちょっと走ったところで
ゴターンと止まったと
何のアナウンスも何もなく
じーっと待たなくちゃいけないんだと
おそらく 1 分間は待てないと思いますよ
乗ってる人々はああだこうだとか
何だろうとかね どんどんどんどん混乱し始めるんです
そこでまあ  1 分間はもうやっと頑張るかもしれません
だけど  2 分  3 分になると
電車の中に閉じ込められている人々はどういう行動をとるかっていうことはわからないんです
ものすごい大騒ぎするかもしれませんし
社長を捕まってぶん殴る可能性もありますね
社長じゃない車掌 何でしたっけ
どうなるかわからないんですね
ドアは開けられますからね
一応 何て言いますか 非常ロックありますからね
で 私は日本のような国では
もうこれ日本 日本以内でそういう混乱が起こるだろうと思います
それはなんでそういうことを言いましたかというと
ちょっと一つポイントがあります
やっぱり知っておけば安全だと
それだけなんですね そこでアナウンスされたところで
まあ人身事故が起きましたと
もうしばらく待ってくださいと言われたら
10 分でも 15 分でも待っているんです
30 分でも待つんです
時々新幹線なんか止まってしまったら
30 分のところじゃなくて
かなりもう閉じ込められて
その中にいる場合はあるんですね
冷静に なんであれほど冷静にいられますかというと
我々は本来よく行儀が良い
よくできている人々 性格はしっかりとできているんだということではありません
我々には情報を伝えられているんです
事実を伝えられているんです
この事実を伝えられていることによって
私たちは混乱を起こさず
苦しみを作らず生きていられるんですね
そこで我々に発見できる一つの論理があるんですね
やっぱり人間には常に正しい情報を与えた方が
人々は落ち着いて幸福でいるんであって
間違っている情報を与えるか
情報は全く与えないかということによって
大変苦しみが生まれるんだと
そういうことはもうほとんどの事実ですね
これをこれは絶対的な真理だとかいう権利は私にありませんだからね
これ絶対的なよということは私にできませんですが
一応かなりの有効性ある事実なんですね
やっぱり人々に正しい情報を与えればよろしいと
で 正しい情報を得ることだけで私たちの心が落ち着くのです
もし正しい情報がなければ
我々はどんな行動をするかということはまず計算できませんし
と言っても計算できるんです
なぜならば もう私たちは生き物だから
すぐ混乱する それで互いに罵り合ったり
殺し合ったりして 大変不幸を作るんですね
そこもほとんど確実なんです
正しい情報なければ 我々は限りない苦しみを作る
限りない戦いをお互いにかなりの苦しみを与えることをします
他人に苦しみを与えることは
自分も苦しんでいるということなんですね
人を殴ったら痛いのは殴られた人ではなくて
殴った人も痛いんですから
そういうことで 私たちの心っていうのは
本来 ちょっとしたことで混乱する
混乱したところでコントロールできない行動に行く
本人にもコントロールできない行動に行く
行って 結果として多大な苦しみを作る
そこで情報を与えただけで心が落ち着く
落ち着いて他人に迷惑もかけませんし
自分にも迷惑をかけませんし
一応しっかりと生きていることはできるんですね
それで私たちは幸福に生きていきたいということを願うならば
一番必要な とても必要なこと
はちゃんと情報を知っていることなんですね
情報というのは 自分に関係ある情報を正しく知ること
それは欠かせない必要な条件なんです
必ずしも必要な条件なんです
そういうことで お釈迦様は智慧の教えというものを教えているんですね
人間に幸福の道を語るならば
智慧の道を語るべきですよと
智慧の方法を語るべきですよと
いかに智慧を実現するべきかと
その方法を語ること自体が本物の幸福の道ですよと
で そこで仏教と科学的な
あるいは日常生活の社会との違うところはそこにあるんですね
例えば医学の世界では
人間にいい薬を作ってあげれば
幸せになるだろうと思っているんですね
それは一部だけなんですね
それは病気になったならばなんですね
そこで次に考え出しちゃうと
やっぱり病気にならなくたっても健康でいなくちゃいけないという栄養学も発展すると
そこで栄養を取ったり
あるいは病気になったら薬を取ったりして
それでいくらかは幸福に苦しみをなくなりますけど
それは一部の仕事なんですね
幸福のもとは未遂で立ち触ってないんです
で 他の機械の文明も同じであってね
新幹線があれば 飛行機があれば
他のいろいろ様々な道具があれば
電子レンジやら洗濯機やらね
それなりに私たちは楽にはなります
でも全体的に楽になるということはないんです
家に洗濯機と電子レンジと
で また冷房 暖房やらね
そういう完備設備は全部完備しているんだと
別に何ももう要りませんと
道具とか何も じゃあそれで私は完璧に幸せかということはないでしょう
ですから この世の中の道はそういう一部一部だけ
何か問題を一部の問題を見て
その一部の問題に何か具体的な答えを出すと
それによって一部的というか
一時的な幸福っていうものは得られるんですね
例えば電子レンジ買っちゃっても
それは故障する可能性もあります
で 壊れたらまた新しいものを買わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
車を買っても それは５ ６
年で使えなくなりますね
そういうことで この物質的な豊かさで
精神的に肉体的に我々は幸せな平和な社会を作ろうと思っても
これはもう準備段階でずっと終わるんだよと
ということは言えますけどね
だからずっと人間どこまでも幸福にならなくちゃと
ということで 経済科学発展し続けなくちゃいけない
発明などはずっとこれからもどこまでもし続けなくてはならないことになっちゃうんですね
これで終わりということはなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで まあ仏教はそれは壊しちゃって
違う道を教えるんじゃなくて
まあ人間にこれ 1本の足で歩くんじゃなくて
やっぱり２本の足で歩きなさいと
今 1本の足で飛んでいるんです
だからすぐ転がっちゃうんですね
我々の歴史を見ると かなり転がっちゃうでしょうね
今も一応ほとんど転がっている状態で飛べないんですね
もう一つ ２本の足  2本目の足つけてあげるんですね
それは智慧の道なんですね
だから智慧の道も付け加えると
普通の我々の生き方に
我々には 2本の足で立てることはできるんです
それで安定するんです
この 2本の 2番目の足っていうのは智慧の道でありますし
そこはどういう論理から成り立つかというと
やっぱり情報さえあれば
正しいインフォメーションさえあれば
私たちは落ち着いて大胆な破壊的な行動にはいかないんだと
危険はやめるんだと それだけで幸福というのは全うするんですね
ですから 科学が完璧に全うする前に
個人個人が幸福というものを全うして完成完了しちゃうということなんです
で 科学は何年経ったら完成するかっていうことはありえないことでしょう
その前に人類も破滅になる可能性ありますし
我々には素晴らしい 完璧な建物やら家やら道具やらね
もう完璧なものができちゃったよということは
まあ論理的にはありえないものなんですね
何のもの どんなもの出来上がったっても
それよりもっと優れたものを次に作らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そういうわけで この科学が完璧になったところで
医学は完璧になったところで
経済学は完璧な理想に上ったところで
人間には問題ないんだと
経済はもう完璧に安定しているんだとか
もう医学は完璧に完成されているんだからと
もうどんな問題であろうか
もうあちらには答えがあるんだと
他の生き方については
どんなもの必要であろうか
そこで科学の世界が作っているんだという
人間には何一つ問題ないんだということはありえないでしょう
ですから 永久的に我々は不完全で幸福を目指す人間で生きていなくちゃいけない
それちょっとかわいそうなんですね
ですから 早くもこの個人個人でまあ幸福というものは完成してつかむという方法はこのちゃんとした情報を知ることなんですね
それで心の安らぎが生まれてくるんです
そういうわけで 正しい情報を知ること自体はまあ知恵なんですね
正しいことを知りましょうと
だから仏教というのはすごく大きい教えかもしれませんだけど
そんなに大きく感じたっても
そちらにあるのは まあ情報はどのように正しい情報とそうでない情報はどのように区別するかと
正しい情報は受けられるように
我々はどのようにすればよろしいかと
そういう智慧の道 だから
その智慧の道を語る場合はいろんなことを言いますよ
仏教は宗教ではないとかね
私の私が言うところから言えばね
まあ信仰なんかはあまり良くないとか
拝むんじゃないとかいろいろよく言うでしょうし
そうするとみんな何言ってるんですかと思うかもしれませんし
せっかく宗教を勉強したくて来たのに
なのにと なぜそのものを否定しているんですかと
矛盾ではないかと でもそういうことを言うのは
やっぱりこれ 智慧の道ですよということを言いたいためなんですね
これでアリストテレスさえもやっぱり一番ありがたいと言ったのはウィスダムでしょ
ウィスダムという英語でいう言葉がありましてね
で 英語だったらやっぱりノレッジという言葉もありますし
ウィスダムという言葉よく使いますね
だから私たちがつかむべきものはお金ではなくて知恵なんです
希望するべきものは財産名誉ではなくて知恵なんです
何に投資するべきかというと
知恵に投資するべきです
すぐその場で私たちは幸福を味わうんです
で 人々はね 株を買ったりして
いろんなそれで幸福になるんだと
商売やったりして それで幸福になるんだというふうに頑張ってますけどね
子供のためだったらお金をいくらでも使いますよとかね
自分何か買いたい やりたいものだったら人殺しでもしますよとか
ゲームやりたい小さな子供が小さくはないんだけど
人まで殺しちゃうんだと
そんな道がみんなやってる道なんですね
だから ちょっと余計な話かもしれませんだけど
この大阪の方に１４歳の男の子がね
まあ何かおばちゃんを殺してしまったと
で ゲームセンターに行きたいだけのことをなんとかなんとか言ってますけどね
だからゲームやりたい
お金欲しいと だから人を殺してやるというのは
それはけしからんだと皆様思いますけど
我々も同じことでしょうに
やっているのは全然別に違う
我々は違うことをやっているんだっていうことじゃないんです
それは同じ道なんです
自分好きなことにもう何かかけてみるんです
それで他の人はもう何億円も借金とかあるでしょうに
銀行潰れるまで潰れるはずがないでしょうし
銀行でのお金を出入りする場所は窓口だけなのに
それ自体も非論理的なんですけど
この株の世界自体も単なる幻覚の世界で
世の中であってはならない現象なんですよ
どこかで何人か集めて遊んでいて
それで遊んでると他のところで会社潰れるんだと
どういうことですかね
ちょっと違う例で考えてみます
どこかで４人ぐらい集めて麻雀やってるんだと
その麻雀のやりとりによって世界経済は決められるんだと
大きな会社がいくつか潰れてしまったと
あまりにもバカバカらしいんじゃないんですかね
それだったらあの１４歳の子供がやった方がもっとしっかりしてるんですけど
比べてみると だからこのあまりにもおかしいことをやって
とにかくもうそちら この株システムできたところで
まあただ何もしないで金儲かると
それにはもう必死になって仕事をしている人々の命を奪っているんでしょうし
人々はいくら技術を持って朝から晩まで苦労して
いろんな産業をやっても
そちらの価値が１日にして消える可能性はありますね
例えば まあ具体的に言えばわかりやすいと思いますけどね
こちらある会社であの１００万円の品物を作りましたと
作る過程ではもう１００万円はかかりました
プロフィットもつけて
それで１００万円で売らなくちゃいけない
そこで品物は向こうへ行ったとする
そこで１円の値段というのは毎日変化しているんですね
それはあの工場の考え方とは関係なく
勝手に変化しているんですね
誰か誰かさんの希望によって
そこで外国に品物を出したんだけど
お金戻る時は百万ではなくて
それはまあ 80万でしたと
言うと この会社が倒れるでしょうに
毎日そんなこと起きてるでしょ
だから真面目に仕事をした人々が損して倒産しなくちゃいけない
どこかでもう単なる数字だけで
私は １億ドル買いますよと
円を円を売りますよと
そういうふうなやりとりだけで
この為替というものは変わってしまっちゃうし
だからこのすごい屁理屈な世界なんですね
ですから この この子供たち
半歳こそ子供たちの生き方と大人の生き方というのは
それほど分優れているとかね
道徳的とかね 知識的とか合理的とか
そんなことは大きなスケールから見ると全然そうじゃありませんね
みんな同じことをやっているだけ
だからこのそういう世界のことを
で いくら頑張っても幸福というものは手に握ることはできません
ですから 知恵というものは一番我々は投資するべき知恵に投資しなくちゃいけない
知恵にかけなくちゃいけない
株に自分持っているお金かけるんじゃなくて
でお釈迦様が言うのは
知恵が得るならば 千千万財産でもいいんだと
捨てなさいと そんな関係ないんだと
それより知恵の方がありがたいんだと
パンニャーナラーナンラタナンというパーリのお釈迦様の言葉がありまして
財産は知恵であると 人間の財産は知恵であると
世の中にはいろいろ光があるんだと
月の星の光と月の光と太陽の光と
4番目 知恵の光もあるんだと
より優れているのは知恵の光ですよと
太陽の光もより優れて強いのは知恵の光だよと
そういうことで いろんなところで知恵ということは
お釈迦様は大変大事に教え
ですね で この智慧と一緒に出てくる言葉っていうのは
落ち着くということであるし
混乱が消えるということ
だからちゃんと情報をそのまま正しく知るならば
その人は完璧に落ち着きますからね
ですから仏教は落ち着きの道だと
解脱の道だと 無執着の道だと
いろいろ言葉ありますが
全部智慧につなげているんですね
これ 智慧が現れたならば出てくる結果なんです
だから智慧のありがたみっていうのは
この 私たちはこの電車でアナウンスされた時を落ち着くような感じでわかるもんなんですね
そこでこの智慧と日本語の英語の言葉は
この knowledge と wisdom というのはそれほど差があるかないか
ちょっとわからないんですけど
これ日本語だったら私たちは ２つの言葉がありますね
知識と智慧という ２つの言葉があります
この知識と智慧っていうのは
まあ知識は智慧ではありませんだけど
だからといってまるっきり切り離すこともできないんですね
なんかすごく あの 何て言いますかね
かなり厳密につなげているんです
知識と智慧っていうのは
でも機能としては全く違うんです
知識って何でしょうかというと
ある角度を決めて ある枠を決めて
ある目的を決めて それについて情報を得ることなんですね
いわゆる制限されているんですね
それは知識というんですね
例えば まあ歴史っていうことはありますね
その世の中で今までどんなものが起きてきたんですかと
それはどういう条件でそういうことが起きてきたんですか？ということを知ろうとする
それは歴史学になっちゃうんですね
そこで専門家にはならないで
それでも本物の一人前の専門家になるためには
地球の全ての歴史を勉強するんじゃなくて
日本史やらフランスの歴史やら
どちらかある一箇所を選んじゃうんですね
あるいはある一時代を選ぶ
ある時代  100年とかなんとかとかね
時代を選んで その時代の歴史とか
それでプロになるんですね
それ知識の世界 だから知識の世界で一人前になればなるほど
確実に幅が狭くならなくてはならないんです
でも その人々はちゃんと正しい情報を得ようとする
もしその人々は正しい情報を得てないならば
これ大変な問題なんですね
医学の世界に比べてみたっても同じことで
一般的に体のことを理解したっても
ちょっとした医学的な知識があるだけで
もうまあ小学校ぐらいでもう教えるぐらいはできるかもしれませんだけど
それ以上何もできませんね
でも それはもっと厳密に体のことだけに吸収して勉強しちゃうと
なんとか医者ぐらいにはなってしまっちゃうんですね
でもそれでも足りませんよ
それでやっぱり自分の専門分野というものを選んで
さらにさらに自分の世界を狭く狭くしたところで
まあ役に立つ一人前になってしまうんですね
だから知識っていうのは
我々の視野がどれぐらい狭いかということによります
視野が狭ければ狭いほど知識人なんです
なんかすごくなんかおかしいでしょうに
視野がすごく広いんだったら
もう何も役に立たない人間なんですね
何でも喋るんだと 何一つものになってないんですね
それは知識の世界 知恵って何でしょうかね
それだったら だから知恵っていうのは
やっぱり もう何も概念ない
心の 心きれいになったら
心はどんな活動をするかっていう
状態のようなものなんですね
今 我々の心は固まってるんですね
ある形をとってるんですね
一旦形をとったら やるべき仕事は決まっちゃうんですね
鉄の塊を持って それで文化包丁を作ったならば
もう仕事はもう決まってるんですね
何をできるかということを
そういうのは知識の世界で
で 知恵っていうのは まあそういうある特別な専門分野に育てたい
育てることではありません
どうもなかなか理解しにくいんです
知恵知恵というとよく喋りますけどね
で わかりやすくする で
私はよく言うのは まあ知識には言葉がありますと
知恵には言葉がありませんと
知識は語れます 知恵は語れません
言葉がない 知識は人に与えることもできます
例えば 私は英語を知っているならば
皆様にも教えてあげることはできます
知恵は不可能です 与えること
語ることも不可能です
でも この知識を得る過程において
我々の心の中で微かに知恵が生まれてくるんです
その世の中で この知識と一緒に何か副産物として知恵が生まれてくるならば
その人々は確実に大物になっちゃうんです
で  もう歴史でも例でもいいんです
単なる歴史は勉強しただけで
世界的な有名な歴史学者になってノーベル賞でももらうということはないんです
で 一緒に歴史なんか勉強するんだけど
ある人だけ特別に輝いているんですね
その人はなんか誰も考えないこととか
誰も気づかなかったこととか
誰でも気づいた方がよく便利で楽ですよという何か発見する
そちらに そのある人にだけ知識
知恵が生まれているんです
一部だけなんですけど
例えば同じ研究部に入っちゃって
4人の研究者がもう研究論文を発表して博士になったとする
その 4人も確実にノーベル賞を取れるぐらいの科学者になるわけじゃないんですね
その中で一人ぐらい何かへんてこりんなことを考えたりして
自分の分野の中でなんか大胆なことを発明したり発見したりする
あの能力なんですね 例えばアインシュタインさんももう単なる簡単単純な数学とかね
そんなことしかやってなかったんだけど
小さい時はそれほど勉強は上手ではなかったという話も聞いていたんだけど
でももう一つ何かあったんですね
変なものは そのなんかもう一つ変なものがありまして
それで巨大な人物になってしまっちゃったんです
そこでアインシュタインさんには
相対論はどういうものかとか
知識は教えられますけど
自分の能力を教えられることも伝えることもできないんですね
アインシュタインの研究所で一緒に研究している人々は
みんなアインシュタインと同じすごい科学者になったかと
そうなってないんでしょ
差は何ですかね それはもう知恵の差なんです
知識だけはもうアインシュタインにはないんですね
だからしょうがないんだけど
もうもし彼の研究所に入ったならば
彼がもう全部教えてくれるんです
でも 一つだけ教えられないものがあるんです
それは知恵なんです だから
これ大変ややこしいものなんですね
音楽の世界も同じでしょうし
音楽を教えてあげることは誰にでもできますけどね
誰にでもじゃなくて やっぱりそういうプロの人には音楽は教えてあげることはできます
全部 でも それで素晴らしい人に
ベートーヴェンになるわけじゃないんですね
世の中にあるありったけの音楽は勉強しますよと習いますよ
全部習います できます
できるんだけど 一人もベートーヴェンにもなりませんし
モーツァルトもなりませんし
バッハにもなりませんしね
だって簡単単純でしょうに
音は決まってるし そのその楽器は作る音も全部決まってるし
それはまあ料理はどうしますかということよりも
やっぱり数学的に考えれば簡単なもんなんです
たくさんものあるわけじゃないんだから
世の中の楽器の種類よりたくさん食べるものの種類多いでしょうに
楽器が作る音と食べ物の作り方を比べたら
そちらの方が多いでしょうに
それだったら短い少ない情報の世界だから
まあどこでもモーツァルトみたいな人々
ベートーヴェンみたいな人々がいるはずなんですね
いない 残念ながら それ
何が違いますかというと
これ 知識と知恵の差なんです
だから絵をどのように絵を描きますかと
先生は教えますけどね
色の塗り方とかね 色の組み合わせとか
筆の使い方とか あるいは基本的にいろんな表現する方法とかね
そういうものはもう大学に入ったら
美術大学なんかに入ったら
もう全部教えてくれる
でもそれで芸術家になるということはないんですね
だから 何が大事でしょうかね
その差のは知恵と知識の差なんです
ですから 結局素晴らしいのは知恵であって
知識ではありません 知恵があるんだったら
やっぱり知識がないことはちょっとハンディにはなりますけどね
例えば私にとってみても
私は喋りたい 皆様に言いたいメッセージがいろいろ持ってますけど
日本語という知識が足らないんだから
そこにすごいハンディがあるんですね
そのすごいハンディがありますから
まあ言いたいものではなくて
全くとんでもないことを言ってしまっちゃうんですね
関係ないものとかね ですから
知識がないと智慧の表現の場合はハンディが起こるんです
だから知識も必要なんですけど
逆に計算してみると 知識さえあればなんとかできるんです
すみません 間違った 知恵さえあれば
知恵さえあればなんとかできます
それはこの仏教では明確に智慧の論がありますからいいんだけど
世の中でなかなかそれはないんですよ
ないんだから いろんな工夫するんですね
例えば 子供が立派な絵なんか描く場合は
まあ大人がこう描きなさい
ああ描きなさいと言ったりする
それで子供は大人に合わせて加工しちゃうと
自分の才能が全部消えてしまう
ですから まあ十六 七 八
八歳になってくると もう絵は絶対描きませんという状態になってしまう
小さい時はもうむちゃくちゃで
壁でもどこでも描くと
で その時はこのまあ昨日耳に入った言葉なんですけど
ある子供に言うんですね
いや あなたは自分で描きたいことを描きなさいと
大人は欲を出して あなたに才能があるんだから
あれ描け これ描けと言うかもしれませんだけど
そうじゃなくて 自分で描きたいものを描きなさいと
自分なりに そういったのも
その人の知恵の世界であることわかってないんです
やっぱりその人が 子供が何か持ってるだろうと
それを発達していければ
抜群な素晴らしい絵を描くだろう
それを大人が自分で判断して
こんな風に描きなさいで
色使いこんな風に使いなさいと言ったところで
才能は死んでしまっちゃうんですね
だから音楽の場合でも同じなんですね
自分感じたものを表現せなさいと
それに必要な知識を与えるんだと
だから知識っていうのはなんかほとんど言語と同じなんですよ
音楽の知識も 絵の訓練的なこの身につく能力
全部全部言語と同じで表現力だけであって
この表現したいものを美しく
人をあっと驚かせるような感じで表現できるのは
知恵があるならばの話なんですね
ですから 我々仏教の世界で智慧っていうのはいろんな
これすごい仏教自体が智慧の世界だから
もう簡単単純じゃないんです
のいろんなランクがあります
この日常生活する中で
我々に必要な知恵に及ぶ
仏教ではパンニャーではなくて
違う言葉が使ってるんです
パティバーナ お釈迦様はこのパティバーナというのは大変ありがたいことだと
普通の世界ではパティバーナさえあれば
あの知恵 これも知恵の一部の働きなんです
パティバーナっていうのは
日本語になると なかなか日本語の言葉あるかどうか分かりませんね
これあの 子供の世界では
英語だったらこのイマジネーションという言葉使ってるでしょ
このイマジネーションというのはすごいややこしい怪しい言葉なんです
それ全く無意味な世界にも
この妄想 空想にも使いますからね
でも ほんの僅かにこのイマジネーションという言葉は子供に使うでしょうね
いろいろイマジネーションあるんだと
いろんなこと いわゆる想像する
想像ですか 想像性と言うんですか？何と言いますか
え？何と言いますかね
想像力 だから想像力 一つパティバーナのちょっとした働きなんですね
でも 想像力だけ取ってみちゃったら
それはもう馬鹿げた話で
もう空想でも妄想でも何でもできますから
これ あまりいいことでもないんですね
だからパティバーナというのは
そんなにこの限りなんて
無制限で このコントロールない妄想
空想ではなくて 何か問題があったらそちらにあっ
こうするべきですよと
すぐ早くも発見する能力なんですね
だからこの想像力という言葉はあまり合わないし
イマジネーションということも合わないし
英語で言えばこのインスピレーションという言葉がありますね
インスピレーション かなもう遠い昔勉強したものだから
私は間違うかもしれませんだけど
最近勉強しないことになってます
インスピレーションは日本語になるとどんな言葉ですかね
ん？直感 えっ 直感力 直感力という言葉はいいかもしれません
パティバーナの場合は
なぜならば 直感力の場合は想像ということほど危険じゃないんですね
想像力だったらもう怪獣でも想像できるし
いいもの悪いものを想像できるんですね
それでもう病気になってしまうところまで想像できるんですからね
直感力っていうのはそうじゃなくて
物事が起きたらすぐ答えが出てくるということなんですね
で このこれ智慧の一部なんですね
ですから私たちは料理の料理を勉強したってもいいし
生け花やってもよろしいし
お琴の稽古をやったっても何でもいいんです
別に 歴史でも科学でも文学でも何でも
でもこれ その自分やってることについて
このインスピレーションさえあれば
なんかすごい役に立っちゃうんですね
そうでないと 単なるまあご苦労様だけなんですね
例えばこのいろいろお琴にしたっても
まあこれ年 年 稽古しているんだと
修行しているんだと 年もやっているんだと
じゃあ演奏してみなさいと言ったら
ああそうかということで終わっちゃうでしょうね
なんか何か足らないんですね
これっていうことを言いにくいんだけど
それはこの歌手の場合もあるでしょ
単なるこの喉から声を出すことだけなんですけど
きちんとこの楽譜にのっとってきれいに声を出せることできる喉の能力がある人々はいくらでもいるんですね
でも 人を圧倒 驚かせるように感動させるようにならないんですね
ある何人かとか ある一人の人が歌うとみんな感動する
同じ能力を持って 同じ歌手の能力を持ってもう一人の人が歌ったっても
ああ 上手ですねと なかなかうまいもんですねということで終わっちゃうんです
評価しちゃうんです あれは本物のプロを歌うと
評価も何もしないで ぼけーとして聞いているんです
だからこの たとえ歌うということにしたっても
これ入ってるんです ですから
知識は当然必要なことで
でも知識だけあってもそれほど役に立つということはないんですね
でも もっともう即的な例で考えましょう
高級ブランド品の服やらセーターやらアクセサリーやら帽子やらね
もうありったけのことを何百万も１千万でも使って払って買っても
すごい品物を持ってるんだということだけで
それですごいおしゃれできる人になるわけじゃないでしょ
もう一つ能力が必要なんですね
ただ ブランドのあれ名前だけで
すごいかっこいいということには絶対ならないんですね
その中にもあるんですね
このインスピレーションの働きが
このベルトはどう使うかっていうこと
この帽子はどうかぶるかということ
だからもうまあ全く無意味の世界なんですけど
日本でももうね ものすごい有名な人いるでしょ
国際的に この花やもりたらああだこうだとかね
僕はそれしか知りませんだけどね
もっとまたいますけどね
まあ世の中一番アホなことをやってますけど
でもすごいそれによって世界を驚かせてるんですね
もう誰でも知ってる もうどうでもいいことから何か発見するでしょ
だから 例えばデザインやら服のことを勉強したい人が花やもりさんのところに弟子入りしてもしたならば
その人はちゃんと教えてはくれるんだけど
2番目の花やもりさんにはなりませんね
そこで仏教でいう仏教では
この知識を与えるんじゃなくて
この智慧を与える 一番ありがたいことなんです
一番ありがたいのはその智慧の世界なんです
それで残念ながら 仏教は今まで勉強してきた人々が
ものすごい知識の塊として
知識として徹底的に仏教を勉強する
一人にもこのパティバーナがない
それ 仏教の世界についてあっても残念なことです
だから仏教学問というものはもうあります
日本だけではなくて アメリカでもイギリスでも
もう時々ヨーロッパの外国でももうちゃんと研究やったりしています
仏教学科というものはあります
仏教学科というわけでもないんだけど
やっぱりインダロジというところがありましてね
インド学 そちらではやってますけど
だからまあ唯識論であろうか
空論であろうか もういっぱいもう哲学やらもう知識の世界っていうのはもういくらでももうありますけどね
何か欠けているんですね
でお釈迦様はこの本当にこの人に言葉を喋りたくて喋ったわけでもないし
何か情報をある特定の情報を持ってきて
これでこれでこれこれだよというふうに知識を与えたわけでもないんですね
だから仏教は頑張ったのは
この簡単に与えにくいものをどのように相手の心に生まれるように
現れるようにしますかということ
花森さんの例を見ても
花森さんのところに行って弟子入りすることは弟子入りしたか分かりません
だけ一応そちらに入って修行することは可能なんです
その人の作品にいろいろもうお手伝いしながら
あっちこっち世界中を回りながら
まあありとあらゆる勉強をすることは可能なんですが
能力さえあれば やる気さえあれば
でも花森さんにできないのは
自分と同じく あるいはもっと世の中を驚かせるぐらいの
何て言いますか 作品を作られるかないかということなんです
大体これぐらいでお分かりになるでしょうね
やっぱり勉強だけでは足らないということ
勉強だけは能じゃないんだと
だからまあ 私の個人的なことを言ってはいけませんだけど
時々人は私はこういうことを勉強しているんだとかね
私はまあこういうこういう学問もやって
こういうこういうものもやって
まあこういうこういう肩書きいろいろ持ってるんだとか
先に言っちゃうと 私の心の中でもうマイナス点いっぱい入ってるんですね
何のことなく もうその人についてはもうすごいもうマイナス点だらけになっちゃうんです
なぜかというと そんなものを出すこと自体も
あなたは危ないんだ ダメだという自分の失格を言ってるんです
肩書きで通用してもらおうと
だから医者についたっても
例えばハガキ 1枚ぐらい
いろんなもう学位取っているかもしれません
特にお医者さんたちの学位の名前長いでしょう
まあ文科系だったらね
まあどうせ PHD だけで終わっちゃいますけど
ディリとかね  DILLITT D
ポイント LITT それは終わっちゃうんですね
医学のそれはそうじゃないでしょうね
一番基本的な MRCP とかね
そちらも 4つですからね
大変なんです ものすごい長い
これ ハガキ 1枚 2枚ぐらいの肩書きを持っていても
患者を治せるかないかということでしょうね
問題が 瞬時に診断できますかと
あ これだったらこうするんだよということ
そこが一番大事なポイントで
ですから まあ医学の中ではまあ一番危ないんですよ
このパティバーナのインチュイションなければ
どうにも役に立たない人を殺す医者になってしまっちゃうんです
なぜかというと 人が来たらテキストを見て薬を決めるんだから
だからお医者様はお医者さんたちの中でも輝いている医者が別にいるんですね
一人一人別に考えていると
でも学問的にももうほとんどみんな同じですよと
そういうわけで とにかくパーリ語でパティバーナという言葉がありまして
それはどんな分野にも当てはまります
音楽も料理にも 子供育てるにも
もう会社の仕事にも どこにでも当てはめる能力なんですね
お釈迦様は言うんです
やっぱり在家の人々がこのパティバーナぐらいあれば幸福になりますと
このパティバーナというものをお釈迦様が定義するのは
どういうこういうふうに定義するんですね
何かその場で その場で問題
いろいろ問題といっても大げさなんですけど
何でも問題ですから その場でその場で立ち向かう
いろいろ問題やらいろんなことあるでしょうに
その場でその場でどうするべきかということをすぐ瞬時にひらめくんだと
その条件 条件によって
それぞれ条件で それぐらいできればもう人生は問題ないんだと
それでやっぱり私にはまるっきり直感能力はないんだとと言って落ち込んじゃっているか
運命論に定めを定められているんだから
まあそんなもんやと あるいは勇気を持って頑張るか
どっちかなんですね 私は生まれつきもうないんだと
直感力なんかはと でも
生きるために必要な直感力っていうのは
どこかの分野で我々にはついてるんです
絵には全く直感力なくても大工さんとしてある可能性はあります
だから人間に知恵のひとかけらはいつでもあるんです
そのひとかけら どこで生きてきますかということを発見するのは
我々の仕事 我々みんなの仕事なんですね
それは世の中でごく一般的に言う才能なんですね
音楽に才能あるんだと
絵に才能あるんだと もうなんとかなんとかに才能あるんだと
スポーツには才能あるんだと
やっぱり不思議なこと
スポーツの世界も同じでしょうに
これは普通の合理的な考えれば
運動すれば誰でもできますよと
そうじゃないでしょ やっぱりみんな同じ能力
体力 能力を持ってるんだけど
そちらも才能あるなしによってもう決まっちゃうんですね
ですから 本当に恵まれていて
例えばあの野球の世界で多彩な方面でできる人は何といいますか
細い人が体が細くて イチローさんですね
だからそういうイチ 一郎さんみたいにね
まあちゃんと野球には才能があって
それなりに理解のある父親がいて
もうちゃんとたたき込んだと
だからその人の場合もいくらか輝かないところはあります
なぜかというと 幅広すぎなんですね
どっちもできるんだから
足は速いし フィールディングはすごいし
バッターとしてもすごいしというと輝かないんですね
やっぱりホームランばっかり打つんだけど
フィールディング守りになっちゃったら
いつでもボールが自分の足から逃げるんだったら
その輝くんですね 我々生きているそれはそんな世界なんですね
あのもっと人気ある人いるでしょ
巨人に入っているこの巨人からは当然出て行っちゃったんですね
あの ちょっと年上の人からあれでしたっけ？落合
落合はバッティングは上手ですけど
他のものは全部下手でしょうね
他の一つもできない できないというのはちょっと大げさですけど
やっぱりその人々と比べるとダメなんです
だから落合とイチローを比べたら
誰が有名で人気ありますか？たくさんのお金
誰が取っているんですかね
それはお金で決めるもんだからね
落合だろうと思いますね
それはどうでもいいんですけど
私たちの世界で必要なのは
やっぱりたとえスポーツにしたっても
このプラスアルファで
この直感というインチュイションというパーリ語でパティバハナというものがあった方が幸せなんですね
だから我々は諦める必要ないんです
で 何かにあるんです 例えば結婚した女の人が
もう家のことをまるっきりむちゃくちゃダメやと
料理したっても もうもう戦争みたいにむちゃくちゃになるんだと
子供が泣いたっても まるっきりもうダメできないんだと
もう女でないんだというふうに
この人を否定するんじゃなくて
これ女で生まれたんだけど
家の主婦業っていうのは全くゼロかもしれませんよ
能力が でもどこかでできる世界があるんですね
子供を産んだんだけど
抱っこすることさえもできないかもしれません
でももしかすると その人は家を出て社会に出たところで
すごい大物で行動できる可能性はありますね
だから我々はこの固定概念ではなくて
その人の人を本来持っているこの才能を生かせる場で動かして活動してもらえば
一番いい世界が出てくるんですね
そこで私たちは説法すると
何に悪口を言ってますかというと
この社会っていうのは人の才能を壊すことで必死になっているんですね
それで私も私は本当に怒らないことに怒っているんです
自分個人的にはね いろんな何が起きても
自分が怒る あまり怒りません
それにものすごく怒っているんです
結局結果は同じですけど
なんでそんなことで腹が立たないかと
で すごく自分が嫌な感じになっちゃうんですね
とにかくこの人間っていうのは
もう人の才能を壊すことでも必死になっていて
殴りたければ殴りたいほど私は腹が立つんです
なんで人の才能を壊すんですかと
で からまあどうも私は出家の世界だから
やっぱり立ち触らないんだと
関係は持たないんだと
あなた方とは ということでも逆に見えているんです
この人はもうあの人の才能は片っ端から壊しているのではないかと
あまりにも恐ろしい だから一番危険なことで
一番罪というのは 人を持ってる才能
むちゃくちゃ壊すことなんですね
それですべての幸福が消えちゃうんです
それ涅槃解脱の幸福を体験する前に
我々は生きる喜びを感じなくちゃいけないでしょうに
どうせ死ぬまで生きてなくちゃいけないんだから
そこでその人の人が充実感感じる世界があるでしょうに
ある人はもうギター ギターでギターですか
そこをいじってものすごい充実感を感じると
ある人はもう畑を耕すことを耕すことによってすごい充実感を感じる
またすごい上手だと ということは
その世界でその人の才能がありますと
その人は自分 自分に簡単にできる
いろんな発明できる世界で
ものすごく自分の精神の家
感じるんです 自分の居所
そこをみんな壊すんですね
だから会社の中に入ったって
みんなストレスの塊になるでしょうに
部下をどう管理するかということで
上の人がむちゃくちゃにもなるでしょうに
なんでそういうふうにシステムができているかというと
やっぱりずいぶんいい加減で
非合理的で 我々この世界を作っているんだからなんです
ですから これはもうまあ理想として言うならば
そのその人が自分が一番やりたい仕事
自分がすごい充実感を感じる仕事
たとえどうであろうとも
その仕事自体がね やらせれば
その人は自分仕事によっても幸福感を感じるし
その仕事をやってもらう人々もいい仕事をしてもらうんですね
でも 私たちの世界 そうじゃないんですね
親が決めるんです 子供の仕事
社会が決めるんで あんたこういう仕事をしなさいと
例えば 生まれ小さい時からこのスポーツに才能があるんだと言って
スポーツ団体というか
そういうところに入るとする
そこで途中でやめる場合あるでしょうに
そのせっかく自分才能あるグループに入っても
その中でその人の才能を育てるんじゃなくて
壊すということをやっているんです
ですから 人を育てる場合はものすごく気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
育てるということは 単なる知識を与えることだけなんですね
知識というのは勉強だけじゃなくて
ピアノを習うことも知識を与えることですから
私たちの言葉では稽古事もスポーツ訓練することも知識を与えることと同じだからね
簡単に教えることできますから
で 知識を与える過程で
このパティバーナとインチュイションは
インチュイションには手触らないこと
あるいはそれはどんどんどんどん成長するように気をつけなくちゃいけない
それはみんな知ってはいるんだけど
壊すんでしょ 例えば 教育の世界で
子供たちの才能はできるだけ伸び伸びと成長してほしいんだということを
みんな口先だけでは言ってます
口先だけで言ってますけど
実際に具体的にその方法では行動しない
例えば これはあまりあまり意味のない例なんですけど
お嫁さんという人に 現れるんだと
そこでその人はまだまだ若いんだだから
自分にはもしかすると主婦としての色々才能はあるかもしれませんし
いきなり固定概念でああではないか
こうではないかと言ってしまったところで
いきなり自分の心が硬くなっちゃうんです
あんたはお嫁だからこうしなくちゃいけないんではないか
ああしなくちゃいけないんではないかと
すると自分で物事を発見して主婦業をやるんではなくて
じゃあ決まりを守ることをやということになったところで
すべての才能が死んじゃうんです
で 固定概念で この才能を死んだ瞬間
みんな味わっていると思います
相手を殺したいほど すごく嫌な気持ちになるんです
この人は鬼だと 死んだ方がいいやと
というふうに他人に対して
まあ死んだ方がいいということはそこまでないかもしれませんだけど
それは文化の差ですからね
僕らの場合は こいつは死んだ方がいいということは思えません
そういう仏教文化だから
まあ嫌な人やということは生まれるんですね
とんでもない人やと あれ
あの瞬間なんです 自分の才能が死んだ瞬間なんです
死んだ瞬間か死にかけている瞬間か
この歳になってましたから
そういう経験ないんでしょうかね
この人だけはすごく嫌だと
で 会社で仕事をしているんだけど
まあ上司に対して散々ああだこうだとか悪口言ってるでしょ
やっぱりそこで上司の方が自分の才能を壊してるんです
だから本人がそれ才能の世界かこの智慧の世界か
そんなことさっぱりわかってないんだけど
本人の大事な幸福を 大事な命の世界を殺してるんです
それは実際に殺されるよりは嫌なんです
実際に 例えばあの上司に何か叱られたとか殴られたとかね
あんまり気にしないんです
そんなことはね 例えば会社でも
まあ誰かがもういい加減あちこち色の歩いたりして
何かもう品物自分の体の上に落ちたとか
その人をこぼしちゃって自分の体の上に落ちたとかね
それですごい大怪我しましたとかね
それであの会社は絶対嫌ですよというふうにはならないんです
何のことなく病院に行って治療を受けて
またぞろぞろと会社に戻るんですけど
でも上司を殺したいほど嫌な気持ちになる時もありますね
それは自分のすごく大事な
自分の大事な才能という命そのものを殺してる瞬間なんですね
そういう あの  離婚の原因もそうであるし
子供がもう親と喧嘩して家出る場合も同じことであるし
で たとえ生きる 二人で一緒に生きることは
たとえ苦しくても お互いの自尊心というところ
傷つけてなけない なれ
傷ついてなければ一緒にいるんです
いくらがいくら大金持ってきたっても
奥さんがもうあなたの顔を二度と見たくないんだと
と逃げる場合 その男の人はその人の大事な
一番大事なところを殺しちゃったんです
その恨みはなかなか消えません
本当に恨みはそこにあるんです
どうしようもないんです
だから人を叱っても人を殴ったっても
それほど恨み持てません
一番恨み持つのは人の才能を壊したところなんです
だから我々はやっぱりそれすごく気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで 結局仏教でいうのは
なぜ仏教では人々はみんなそれぞれ個人であって自由ですよと
それも一つのポイントなんです
私にとっては私の 私は弟子をいて
その弟子が音楽家にしてやるぞと思ったっても
そういうことは不可能なんです
私に説法できるんだから
自分の弟子も説法師にしてやるぞと思って頑張っても
ただ弟子に殺されるかもしれません
ただそれだけ それは不可能なんです
それぞれの人がいくらかのパティバーナを持って生まれてくるんです
それは育てられますけど
だからお互いに自由なんです
親はあるパティバーナ持っていて
子供はあるパティバーナが持って生まれてくるんです
で 親の仕事は自分持っている能力を全部子供に注ぐんではなくて
子供が持って生まれたものを育てるように自由にしてあげることなんです
放っておくことなんです
邪魔しないことなんです
そういうわけで 人にはもう一人の人を支配することは不可能なんです
そんなものはすべて強引で残酷なんです
この支配する 管理する
コントロールする ありえないんです
それは権力 暴力でしかできません
我々実際に生きている世界っていうのは暴力の世界なんですね
言葉の暴力 お金の暴力
権力の暴力 そういうことで人々を抑えて抑えて
いじめていじめて憎んですね
そこでたまたま一人二人
それに反対して立ち上がって
一人歩きをして 世の中に素晴らしいものを残して死んじゃうでしょう
だからベートーヴェンさんなんかは少ないんです
アインシュタインみたいな人々も少ないんですね
かなり頑固者でないと
殺されるんだから まあ一応今日はなんかこの状況
単なる講義みたいな感じで
この説明だけで役に立ちませんだけど
一応理解としてはそこら辺は理解していただきたいんですね
あの 知識っていうのは与えられる
教えられる 頑張れば 例えば英語だけではなくて
もうちょっと時間さえあれば
もうギリシア語もフランス語もドイツ語も何でも勉強できるんです
でもそれはものになるということはまた別な話で
そちらへんはまあ 例えばヨーロッパの言葉はまあ１０ぐらい覚えたんだと
でもよく喋ったり書いたりできるのはたった一つだけということあるでしょうね
そちらには自分の才能の世界で
そういう 知識は与えられます
教えられます 知恵は与えられません
教えられません それはその本人
本人が持っている火種をどんどん増やしてあげるように環境を作るしかできません
で 我々は本当にどんなパワーで
どんな力で幸福で生きていますかというと
才能の世界で生きているのであって
知識はで幸福は感じません
工学はどこまで勉強したっても
だからといって喜びは感じませんよ
それをもって自分が何かやったならば
あれすごい一生自慢になっちゃうんですね
ということで 生きる場合は
いろんなところで どんな知識にしたっても
それとつなげて知恵の世界があります
音楽もそれにつなげて知恵
知恵の世界があります
医学だったらそれに知恵の世界またあります
車の整備士になったっても
それはある一つの分野で
その中にまた知恵ということを
またそこにもあります
そうやってまあ 各仕事分野において知恵の世界があります
子育てにも主婦業にも知恵の世界があります
そこで老人になったところで
いろいろあのグループを作ったり
団体を作ったり いろいろ活動しているでしょ
社会的な活動 ボランティアとかね
その中にも知恵あるとないという差がちゃんとあります
ですから その知恵というわけもわからない
得体も知れない でも確実に自分たちが持っている
その才能の世界 直感の世界だけは大事にしてほしい
それを育ててほしい もし私たちは人生は本当にもうなんて退屈だと
つまらないんだと 生きている生きること自体はもう嫌で嫌でしょうがないんだと
というならば その人は全く見つかっていないんですね
自分を生まれて持ってきた
この直感の世界 使ったことはない
発見したことはない ただそれだけ
それを発見すると 退屈だ
つまらないんだということは消えちゃうんです
それでまた仏教違うことを言うんですね
それちょっと違う言葉がありまして
じゃあだから人々は自分の才能はみんなそれぞれ持っている才能は発見しましたと
言うと みんな思い存分生にしがみついて
生きているではないかと
それで仏教の無執着の教えって何でしょうかと
という問題もあり得るんですね
だから我々はこの全体的な知恵のことを喋っているんですね
だから全体的な知恵のことを喋っているんだから
例えば椅子だけ作れる大工さんがいるんだと
椅子だったらもうものすごい才能があるんだと
でもその人がそれだけ人生じゃないんだということもわかっているはずなんですね
それだけ人生じゃないんだと
それ発見することによって
死ぬまで充実して生きていられることはできます
それで終わっちゃうんですね
音楽家は死ぬまで音楽を奏でることだけで生きていて
後で虚しく死んじゃう
で この自分僅かに持っている知恵を持って
この生命についての多次元的に知恵を育ててみると
まあすべてを捨てて解脱するということは体験できるんですね
だから解脱ということは
この知恵の完成なんです
だから知恵の完成は解脱やと
もう何のことなく 仏教の経典でもどこでも言ってますからね
だから大変な面白い世界なんです
執着はないんです なぜかというと
執着するのは何か弱みがあるんだからなんです
何か弱みがある 何か才能がない
だから執着するんです
簡単な例で考えましょう
会社にすごく執着しているんだと
リストラにならないように必死やと
ということは才能がないということでしょ
堂々と仕事できるんだったら
もう堂々と仕事をする
あんた方 私をクビにしたければどうぞクビにしなさいと
他のところでもどこでも私は受け入れるんだと
と堂々と言っているんですね
ですから なんとかペコペコペコペコみんなにお茶を運んだり
何でもやって 掃除も何でもかんでもやって
機嫌をとって とにかくしがみついていたいと思ったら
もう才能がないということなんです
昨日 テレビでこの喫煙じゃなくて禁煙のなんとかことについてちょっとした番組があって
そこである学校かな 塾かな
僕はもう本当に真面目に見てないんだから
もういい加減ちょっとちょっとの感じだから
なかなか例に出せませんだから
そこである学校みたいなところなんですけど
厳密に禁煙にして もうみんなということで
すごい厳しいんですね
2002年ではもう絶対的にすべて禁煙にするんだと
でも 一人の人だけは問題だと
もうだから禁煙だったら
そこじゃクビなんですね
タバコ吸ったらそれぐらい厳しいんです
だから そういうふうにクビにした人々の名前を見せたんですね
タバコ吸ったんだから
もう辞めてもらったんだと
でも 一人の女の人はそれでも仕事をしているんです
なぜかその人を言うんですね
この社長という人かな
やっぱりあの人は仕事はすごい上手だと
ものすごい仕事が上手だと
ただそれだけ だから彼女には私のプライバシー
私の趣味だから タバコ吸うことはね
それにはいちいち口出すなと
他の人はタバコ吸っちゃったらクビ
あの人はもうタバコ吸ってるんです
でもクビにならない はっきりと言われるでしょうに
もう仕事には抜群に才能があるんだから
もうタバコ吸うか何しようか
もうもうとにかくこちら社長の方でお願いしますすることしか何もないんです
ですから この執着するということは
下手で才能ないということなんです
もし我々は家族に執着しているんだったら弱いんですね
お金に囚われているんだったら
ものすごい弱いということなんです
健康であろうが 長生きしたいとかね
ただ単に自分の悩み 弱み
才能のなささ わめいているだけなんです
嘆き喚きだけのことなんです
だから智慧が完成したところでもう大丈夫
何もなくてもいいんだと
だからお釈迦様は王子様で生まれて
国も捨てて すべて捨てて
何も持たないで どれほど勇気あると思いますか？ クレジットカードを持っていかなかったんです
何も 大丈夫だということでしょうに
だから自信があったんです
真理を探すんだと 幸福の道を見つかるんだと
で 気が弱い 根性が曲がっている人々だったら
あんたせっかくおじさまで生まれたんだからね
まあ一応楽に生活した方がいいんじゃないかと
それそんなにも出家したければ
家来のをね  20人ぐらいでも連れて行った方がいいんじゃないかとかね
料理作ってくれる人とかね
身の回りの面倒を見てくれる人とかね
連れていけばいいんじゃないかなと言うかも
それは世間の話で いかに弱いかと
いかに才能ないかという話なんですね
実際にある例があったんです
ある このお金のある人が
出家したくなったんです
結構財産があったんです
で それでその人が もう仕事はしたくないんだと
十分だと それでこれから修行の世界に頑張りますということで出家を決めて
一応商売とかそれは全部片付いて
自分にはまあ死ぬまでぐらいの食べる分
一応一つ家を作って 修行者にふさわしい家を作って
そちらで料理作る 召使いとかね
一人ぐらい まああまり大げさ贅沢ではないんです
一人二人ぐらいとかね
自分の家の掃除している人とかね
で ちゃんと用意して そちらにちゃんとお金入るようにして
で 自分がもう何もそういうことを考えずに
朝から晩まで修行に励めばいいんです
あちらはちゃんと食べ物を作ってくれる
部屋の掃除やら全部やってくれるというふうに
すごく厳密に計画を立てて出家したんです
それは現代我々の考え方でいえばしっかりしているんですね
いい加減じゃないでしょうに
出家するんだから やっぱり将来のこともちゃんと考えて
死ぬまでのこともきちんと経済学的に考えて
面倒を見てくれる人々があって
その人々にちゃんと死ぬまでの給料をちゃんと与える
もらうようにして 楽に修行できるんですね
それで出家したんです
とにかく出家して 家なんかを全部処分しましたからね
自分がお寺 ちょっとしたお寺を作ったんだからね
そこで泊まって修行を始めたんです
その話をお釈迦様が聞いたんです
聞いたら あの人は誰にも迷惑をかけない立派な人だと言ったんではなくて
お釈迦様はなんとことをするんですか
全部没収だと 全部没収して追い出しちゃったんです
という立場なんです せっかくもう誰に迷惑をかけないで
軽々と真面目に修行しようと思ったんだけどね
お釈迦様は選択をさせ
あなたは出家やめるか
全財産捨てるか どっちかと
出家はやめたくないんだと
それだったらあなたの建物も全部没収と
そこに住むことも禁じ
厳しいんです だからそちらはきちんとお釈迦様の論理はきちんとあるんです
ものすごい合理的で そんな弱みを持って
自分の体のことにそれぐらい心配しながら
解脱なんかできるわけないでしょうに
これ才能は完璧に完成する世界だから
智慧を完成する世界だから同時に心配っていうのは消えるはずなんです
全ての心配消えるはずなんですね
この人は心配ごとそのまま運んでいくんだから
そのレベルからは一歩も進めないでしょうに
だから 財産に威張る人は一歩も智慧の方に進まない
自分の名誉に 自分の肩書きに
自分の体の体力に 美しさに威張っちゃうと
それだけで才能ないということなんですね
進めないんです だから智慧が完成すると同時に
性に執着してしがみ込んで
もう解脱の反対の方に行くと言ったっても
それはありえないんです
才能ある人はもう何でも捨てる
心配ないんだと  悪い例なんですけど
私を知っている 大体ほんのちょっとの年上の人なんですけど
一緒に学校に勉強したお坊さんで
であまりまあ我々の仲間の中ではね
それほど評価する人ではなかったんだけどね
で とにかく大学終わったらインド行きたかったんですね
そこでとにかくインドへ行っちゃったんですね
インドで勉強しようと行ったんだけど
どうせスリランカ人だからお金あるわけじゃないんですね
家からお金を送ってもらうこともできねぇ
お金あるわけじゃないし
お寺にもそんなにあるわけじゃないし
それでもやっぱり行って勉強したいっていう
なんかベナレス大学かどこかに入ったんですね
入ってすごく苦労して
もうなんとかなんとか苦労して
もうなんとかまあ一応勉強を始めたんですね
そこで彼があの それでもかなりうまくいったんです
でもうかなり年取ったところで
もう私が会っても いろいろ私が話している時はね
まああんたどうやってインドで勉強したんですか？と言ったら
お金もなかったでしょうと
あ それ何のこともないんだと
何ですか？いろいろお金とか何とかなくなってくると
あっちこち旅に出るんですね
お金は持ってないんですよ
あっち行きたい こっち行きたいと結構歩くんですね
どうやって歩くかというと
どこかに座って で 一応お坊さんですね
友達だから だからインドの世界では
この色っていうのは まあ一応宗教の世界だからね
誰かがインド人とかだったら
もうこっちいらっしゃいと言って占ってくるんです
どんなも手相とかね 占ってあげるんだと
それであんたを手相とか知ってますか？そんな知るわけないでしょ
そんな知るわけないでしょうと
これ 占いの本場なんですね
インドっていうのは こういう占いについては
このもう３０００年の歴史なんです
もう記録している歴史
あの連中騙しちゃうんだから
騙すって言ったっても
まあ一応顔を見たらね
こう まあ一応お坊さんだから
いくらかは人の心をつかめるようにしゃべることできるし
口がどうしてもものすごく上手でしたしね
まあものすごい上手でしたし
そこでもう何のことなくお金入るんだと
そこであ これぐらいで十分だなと思ったら
それであの汽車にお金払って
またすぐに村に行ったりと
でも全部当たるんだと言ってることは
だからその人を本当のところ言えば
まあ仏教の世界だからね
そんなものはどうでもいいということはあるかもしれませんだけどね
やっぱりあの 自分にはなんとか自分の生きることを
自分に必要な収入を得ることにはもう才能あるということで
もう怖いものないんですね
今は結構有名になってますけどね
今もこのアメリカ人からいろいろ人々がもう結構来るんです
占ってほしくて だから僕らはからかうんだからもう隠れてやるんですね
私はもう最近 あんたよくもそんなことやるんですと言ったら
どうすればいいんですかと
みんな一生懸命来るんだからと
いい加減なことをいい加減なことを言ってますけど
みんなに合ってるんだからしょうがないでしょ
言ってること 言ってることはちゃんと当たってるんだからしょうがないのだ
だから今そんなことなくてもちゃんと生活はできるんだけど
やっぱりそういう人を聞きたいことを言える
占いっていうのはそんなもんなんですね
聞きたいことを言ってあげる
だから相手が何が聞きたがっているかと
すぐ感知できる だから
それだけの能力でも人には生きていられるんです
けしからんな商売かもしれませんだけど
そちらにも才能があればうまくいくということで
だからその例は決して役に立たない例なんですけど
まあ強引に役に立つ 役に立つんじゃなくて
理解するならば だからもう何も当てもないのに
ドーンとインドに行ったし
それ終わって何のこともなくアメリカに行ったんです
そこでもうちゃんと結構大きな音を立てて頑張っているんです
アメリカの一人のお坊さんの話なんです
ですから 才能ある人にとっては何がないかというと心配はない
将来のためにいろんなものを持っていくかというと
何も持っていかない そういう精神ですから
知恵の完成っていうのは
決してこの弱肉強食の
このこの才能ない連中のこの争いに巻き込まれて一緒に戦うということはありえないんです
なんで我々の世界でお互いにもう争いばっかりでしょうに
食い争いでしょうに あれ
才能ないんだからなんです
みんなに才能ない だから相手の足を引っ張ろうと
いろんなことをしているんです
企業秘密はあるわ もう情報は盗むわ
あの野球にしたってもサインは盗むわとか
まあ才能ないんだという
たったそれだけでしょうに
爆弾を落とすわ 人を殺すわと
だからこの世の中で我々はこの競争世界は決して正当化してはいけないんです
競争あるということ自体は
あなた方はもう下手でも生きる権利もないということなんです
だから下手なのはしょうがないんだけど
せっかく何か才能を持って生まれたでしょうに
それを育ててみなさいと
そうすると相手を殺す必要なくなっちゃうんだと
もし奥さんの才能が旦那さんが殺す殺すんだったら
奥さんに旦那さん殺されるんですよ
具体的に体を毒でも飲まされちゃって
もし旦那さんが奥さんの才能はどんどんどんどん発達するように放っておくならば
放っておけばいいんです
そこら辺で応援するだけで
そうするとお互い死ぬまで互いに助け合ってうまくいくんです
心配する必要ないんです
だから結局世の中にあるのは
このいわゆる一般的に才能というか
パティバーナというか
知恵の問題なんですね
だから私たちはずっとこの仏教というものは幸福の教えであって
幸福の幸福の宗教というならば
仏教しかないんだと いい加減なことを言っているのは
いい加減ではないんだからなんです
この才能ない人々から見ればいい加減になりますけどね
幸福の教えだとキリスト教も自分で幸福の教えだというんだからとかね
で 他の宗教も幸福な教えだと言っているのではないかと
でも我々は違いますよと
あれは才能が壊しちゃいますよと
例えば何かを信じる 何かに守られて生きているということ自体で才能は消えるでしょうね
例えば偉大なる神様に守られて
生きているんだと 神様はちゃんと守っているんだから大丈夫だと
それだけでも その人の才能は消えちゃうんです
日本でお守りと同じなんですね
それよりは向こうの方が力強いんです
日本の周りお守りというのはまるっきり効き目ないということはみんな知ってるんだけどね
やっぱりまあそれでも使うと
やっぱりそんなこの遊びじゃないんですね
ヨーロッパ人にとって神という概念というのは遊びじゃないんです
日本人にはそれとりたして遊びだけですからね
あと３日 ４日ですかね
みんなの家で持っていくでしょう
なんかあの 何ですか あれ
長いスティック かまやとかね
持ってきて もう一年間
ではっきり言えば もう結局遊び
遊びでもうみんなやってるんだからやってるということでね
まあ犬猫と同じことですから
大したことないんですけど
もう一大大事なことやとということは思ってないんですね
ですから そこら辺は別に問題ないんだけど
ヨーロッパ人にとっては
神という概念というのは大変な概念なんです
だからお祈りして アイビリーフゴッドというのはものすごい言葉なんです
ということは もうどうしようもない時
真面目にアイビリーフゴッドと言うんです
それだけで才能はないということにもなる
才能は死ぬ アイドントビリーフゴッドという人が自分で頑張るんです
そういうことで このなぜ仏教と他の宗教と色々比べてみますと
けど このどこが違うかというと
この才能を殺すところは全部仏教は反対する
本来の才能をちゃんと育ててくれるならば
そこら辺にはもう全然文句言わない
ですから まあ私 仏教の場合は目的ちゃんと決まってあって
これ人間は智慧を発達させなくちゃいけないんだと
知恵を智慧を発達することにことを妨げるすべてのものは非道徳だと
簡単に決めそべるんです
だから道徳 非道徳っていうのは
ただ人殺しとかそれだけじゃないんです
だから麻薬でも非道徳を罪の方に入れているんです
才能を殺しちゃいますから
噂話 ゴシップやるなと
全て我々が本来持っている
この微かな才能も殺してしまうんですね
食べ過ぎも良くないんだと
寝過ぎはダメやと 怠けは絶対ダメだと
だから他の宗教と違って
仏教の道徳世界は何かそういう風に複雑なんですね
複雑ですけど きちんと心理学的にこの能力開発のためにできているんです
能力開発というのはあまり俗っぽい言葉なんですけど
知恵の開発のためにできているんです
だから私の話はずっと真面目に聞いてても
私は全然ありがたみを何も感じない
はっきり言うと なぜかというと
私はちょっと監視しているんです
本来 そのその人々が持っている能力はというか
この知恵の火種がどんどん大きくなってくるかないかと
それ大きくなってくるなとわかったら
私はすごく喜びを まあそれはまあ良かったという共感は感じるんですね
そうでなく 単なる話はじーっと聞いているだけで
すっごく嫌なんですね
それは すごく嫌なんです
地べたに聞いているんだと
全部録音して もう全部取ってるんだと
あれほど嫌なことはないんですね
馬鹿にするんじゃないという話なん
僕の立場で言えば あんた方に漫才言ってるわけじゃないんだと
で だからそこは全然何の意味もないんですね
こういう話を聞いて 我々の本来持っている
我々の物事を見られる能力
客観的に物事を見られる能力
この悩み事 心配事を消える方向へ
持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
で まあ時々皆様の中でいくら何人何人かがいますけどね
まあなんとなく自信ついたとかね
という人々はいるでしょうと思いますし
で かえって私にあーではないか
こうではないかとか いろいろいろんなことを喋ってくれる場合もあるし
で その場合はやっぱり自分で
まあ自分の心が自分でもう初めて生きていようではないかと思っているというところなんですね
ですから こういう話を聞いたっても
そのまま鵜呑みにして
丸暗記して覚えておいたっても意味がない
どんな説法にしたっても
やっぱりこれは言葉で喋るものはすべて知識であって
知恵ではありません で
自分に知恵があるかないかというと
試す方法はありますね
もし私が喋っていることでも何でもいいんだけどね
ちゃんとメモを取って覚えておいて
同じ講義を分ぐらいやってみてくださいと
できればいくらかポイントをあげます
今日のテーマでもいいんです
で そこら辺 私はわざと授業にならないように喋ってるんです
これ大学の授業のようにだったら
何の音もなく教典はもう覚えているし
そちらでこう言っても
あちらでこう言ったら
こちらでこう言っているとかね
何のことなくできますけどね
はい  それではですね 先生はここで最初やられる時に
私が幸せでありますようにと言いますよね
一体それは誰に頼んでいるんです
うん まあ誰にも頼んでないんです
わかりました  もし他の言葉あればね
いいんですけど  はい じゃあ一応あのまあ一部ですから
一応知恵の世界を紹介しただけで
あのまあ知恵がどうこうどう頑張れば生まれてくるかという方向を来年ですか
お話しさせていただきます
時間はもうちょっとオーバーになりましたので
で もしまあいろいろ ご質問とかね
受けられますけど じゃあどうもありがとうございます
どうもありがとうございます